comment avez-vous annoncé la nouvelle à
votre fils
alors je t'ai annoncé en deux fois
première fois je lui ai dit que son père
avait eu un accident
au ski et que il était parti à l'hôpital
et qu'on attendait des nouvelles mais je
savais déjà qu'en fait il était en mort
cérébrale
et
après le lendemain j'ai dû j'ai dû lui
annoncer que son père ne s'était pas
réveillé que il était mort je l'ai fait
en deux fois parce que parce que même
moi j'avais l'impression on sait pas
qu'il a été débranché on a toujours
cette espèce d'impression que
ce que c'est coma mort cérébral en fait
il y a plein de choses on comprend pas
trop et c'était aussi
même une espèce de
un cheminement aussi pour moi c'est à
dire j'y croyais même pas le jour où on
me l'a annoncé la première fois il a dit
un accident je pense que ça va aller
parce que il regardait c'était une
période où il regardait une série
même versus wild et il me parlait de du
héros qui avait eu un accident qui était
dans le coma mais en fait il avait perdu
la mémoire était devenu amnésie donc il
m'a dit peut-être que ça va être pareil
pour papa peut-être qu'il va être
amnésique mais pendant quelques jours et
puis après il va se réveiller ça ira je
pense que à ce moment là je je vais des
sangles dans la gorge et je suis partie
de mon côté et le lendemain quand je lui
ai vraiment annoncé et il m'a dit mais
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible et
pleurer est-ce qu'il faut tout
dire il faut dire le maximum il faut il
faut pas mentir en tout cas je sais pas
j'ai pas dit papa est parti au ciel ou
sinon et là je pense qu'il aurait
passé sa vie à regarder les étoiles non
son papa il fait il fallait lui dire les
choses
simplement et
et il a compris en fait on sait jamais
si on fait bien les choses est-ce que
j'ai utilisé les bons mots mais en tout
cas j'ai essayé de lui dire les choses
le plus simplement possible je suis pas
rentrée dans les détails de l'accident
pourquoi
parce que
ça c'était avec une autre personne enfin
il y a une collision Gaspard avec un
autre skieur et que je trouvais ça
extrêmement violent à raconter à mon
fils et je voulais pas qu'il en veuille
en fait à une autre une tierce personne
alors j'ai pas demandé de conseils
parce que pour l'annonce de sa mort plus
pour l'après j'ai une amie qui est
qui est psy
j'avais pris deux trois avis de psy plus
par rapport à l'enterrement et je pense
qu'il était important en fait qu'il
assiste aux obsèques de son père pour se
rendre compte que son père était parti
c'est le rôle d'une maman de de protéger
et d'accompagner au mieux son enfant son
papa a été très connu est-ce que vous
redoutez le fait qu'il soit confronté à
des images dans les médias la télé ou de
ses camarades à l'école qui lui
expliquent voilà
la façon dont on n'a pas est décédée
alors il est il est jeune enfin il a 7
ans mais il avait 6 ans au moment de
l'accident
on a pas de télé donc il a pas vu
d'images
à la télé on il a pas accès au réseau
sociaux heureusement donc il s'en est
vraiment rendu compte le jour des
obsèques parce qu'il a vu énormément de
monde des photographes et c'est là où il
m'a posé la question et qu'il a compris
que son papa était quelqu'un de connu
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que votre fils
garde de son père
je veux qu'il garde je veux qu'il
n'oublie pas je veux qu'il garde les
souvenirs qu'il a alors je sais pas je à
6 ans j'ai l'impression qu'il a
énormément de souvenirs même de très
petits avec son papa
et je je souhaite
vraiment qu'il le garde ses souvenirs
pour toujours
auquel j'ai rajouté
ce livre qui est qui est un objet que
que je lui tends pour aussi
faire oeuvre de mémoire et et où il
pourra retrouver son papa quand il sera
plus grand
vous a aidé vous dans votre deuil moi
c'est ce que c'est ce que je dis dans le
livre c'est que ça a été un refuge
littérature d'abord avec mes lectures et
l'écriture aussi
là où d'autres iraient parler à des
psir entouré en thérapie moi c'était
c'était par l'écriture
[Musique]